okay hi everyone we are here doing open
language design review continuing uh
foreign function related
functionality
so Christopher where did we get to last
time
right so let me see so I think one of
the things from last time was we talked
about having a foreign function load
like there's Library function load and
then there's a foreign function object
that returns so yeah we that's now
implemented
um so remind me that first argument
there
is from find library that that thing is
a tag what is that yes I forget if if we
had this last time I think we might not
have so basically this so this is now
kind of a required argument this is
basically just the it's the same as the
first argument's Library function load
it's the it's the path to the library or
it's the name of the library that it
will call find library on
um and is that ultimately a file or is
that something more complicated in some
registry somewhere so right now it is
ultimately a file
um there's actually a concept which I
think is a little bit
orthogonal to this because it would
apply to the library function functions
as well but the idea would be to support
either have some kind of Library object
or to support lists in these all these
places that expect libraries because
basically there are
uh well they're they're basically there
are lots of cases where you have Dynamic
libraries that depend on each other and
often where they care about things like
the the load order right you have to
load one before the other
and so
right so so normally the way that you
like to use foreign function node and I
have a real example that I can show in a
minute is you just you sort of lazily
load all your functions by calling you
know foreign function node like this and
this will check if this is loaded and if
it isn't it will load it right but the
problem is suppose this had a dependency
now now you have to make sure the
dependency is loaded first and the usual
way you do that is you explicitly call
library load but you can't really do
that lazily so so that the better thing
would be if you could put a list there
and then it would you know it would load
all of them presumably from left to
right or something like that and then
there have to be some convention about
probably the last element is the one
that it actually gets this symbols from
because it doesn't it does at least on
Windows need to know which library is
add one actually in
um
I mean something like get doesn't have
or needs does not have needs doesn't
doesn't needs have a way of dealing with
subsidiary
dependent files and so on
well dependencies in in package files
are handled not in load time yeah in the
package file yeah right you can't do
that with libraries so
you can't put the dependency to a
library in the library
like I can with some static linking but
you don't know that they've done that I
would have thought that we'd be better
off on associations that first argument
or something like that where we say you
know Library Arrow whatever dependency
error whatever or maybe a library object
yeah
well now I thought I mean I know on Mac
OS like Dynamic libraries can list the
other libraries they depend on
but you can't you can't load them you
can't load a library and then say Oh
what libraries do you need to load you
can't do that yes
you can use system tools things like
otol to query them as to find out what
the difference is but that's pretty
hairy stuff and you don't get totally
and it's it's it's it's deeply platform
dependent and also there's there's
there's there's sort of hard
right there's things like oh you just
built openssl right openssl has lib
crypto and labessa cell and you have to
load to load oh you have to load lib SSL
first maybe they didn't set that though
in all the different flags you know what
are you gonna do so all right so your
proposal is to have a library object and
it surely should be called Library
object
sure yeah I mean either that or a list
right I think both of these would would
work
um the list is maybe a little less
explicit
well I'm thinking though you should
distinguish the you know maybe it's a
list
maybe it's the name of the actual
library and then maybe it's arrows or
something something where they where
there's a sub list of dependencies so
maybe it's just like it's like the like
this or something
yeah something like that
or maybe even the other way around but
that would be I personally think those
are that's rule abuse in my mind there's
an arrow there yeah it is real abuse
so maybe it's a sub list
maybe instead of the rule it's just a
list there
right the only reason to have the base
name last if you don't have a another
layer of list is that it's the one
that's going to be loaded last no I know
I know you have to have another layer of
list but I'm sure something like this
right and then then the full form of
that could be some kind of Association
that explicitly calls out this is the
library this is the you know because
there might be Library paths that are in
common and things
so there could be a an association
version of that
I mean I know that this is kind of just
convenient syntax but how often do we
expect people to actually be duplicating
this dependency information in every one
of their foreign function load calls
because I would imagine that these
dependencies are kind of an
implementation detail of the the main
library I totally agree with that I
totally agree with that right this is
why so I mean yes one of the other
important points that like on different
platforms like for example on Windows I
think they're like there's either one or
three libraries for open SSL instead of
two right and they're different okay so
that raises another point if there's a
library object maybe it needs an
association a platform dependent
Association well maybe so okay so maybe
right so I think the two versions would
be either you have a platform dependent
Association but that's a little weird
because it means your library object you
know on Mac OS now has a bunch of
references to a bunch of Windows File
names that just don't exist on your
computer right
another version that's part of the life
in the jungle
sure sure another version would be that
basically wherever you set because I
think a lot of the time you're going to
set you know here's you know dollar you
know the library I'm you know using
equals and then you do switch
and then you you know look at your uh
you look at your you know dollar system
ID or something
and you say if I'm on Mac you know then
I want this library and if I'm on you
know windows I don't want this other one
right
um I mean this is the sort of most naive
way you do annoying to have to do that I
mean it would seem nicer to be able to
put that in an association so this is
the alternative is yeah
well I do think I mean
like having a symbolic representation
for this is feels a little academic for
this specific problem because at the end
of the day this is a stateful thing like
you've loaded a library or you haven't
and
you kind of as the developer need to be
sure that you're doing that at the right
moment and you only need to do it once
you're not going to be kind of unloading
and loading libraries and you know
having a computable object to do that
with is of limited value I think yeah
and it's a global thing you can't have
different ones in different places it's
fixed for your session oh yeah so what
are you guys proposing
what I would propose is basically
something like this where you're going
to set it and it's going to be specific
to your platform like this is really
just a reference to your computer it's
like saying file right file of Str you
know some string
fair enough but it seems like the point
being made that farm function load
shouldn't have to have the dependencies
you know it should just be able to refer
to a library object because you don't
want to repeat for every one of the 18
functions that you're defining you don't
want to have to repeat well actually
here's the question the the two the two
ways to avoid that I think one is that
the most the way it works right now
which I think is honestly Pretty Natural
which is just you set a variable right
I'll show you I have a real example I'm
going to show in a moment that shows a
lot of the conventions I think we want
to promote and and it's very common just
you know have a dollar my library you
know and then have that in all of your
files and you just always put that here
the other alternative would be that just
like you can append to the library path
maybe you can append to some kind of
registry of named Library things and I
can register that the string open SSL
you know
refers you know I don't think we've had
a huge success that's what we've done
with entity stores
this is bad also because there's all
sorts of collision opportunities it's
it's symbols are scoped strings are not
yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay
all right so provisionally you're saying
it's up to the user to manage that
basically the the syntax would be it's a
list in the first argument of foreign
function load and the typical sort of
workflow would be to have a variable you
know a global variable that's set to
what that's supposed to be
yeah although I I would argue I mean
maybe the I don't know whether it's the
list or the library object I kind of
like the library object but Library
object is nice yeah okay fine and this
would presumably be supported by all of
the different you know Library load
would support this Library function load
would support this
Etc yeah okay
all right I think that sounds
right I think that that that sounds good
um
right so now let me maybe show the the
uh the example so I made a little
example not that's particularly
practical but just just because it shows
some of the conventions so it's it's a
connection to postgres because I was
doing something with postgres so yeah
I'm running a postgres server over here
on my computer and if I you know run
postgres connect it will connect you
know there's good uh because it's women
that's part of your postgres yes yeah I
have two functions postgres connect and
postgres execute and then a couple of
objects
um you know if I give it the wrong thing
it'll give me a proper error message
which it got from you know this is a
string that it came from postgres and so
on
um and then I can try you know running a
query and getting back a result object
and then you know I can ask for you know
the data set from the result object and
you know
material this particular functionality
relates to our whole giant database
calling functionality oh I mean there's
already there's already existing stuff
that basically does this in the database
system
so this is not super practical right
okay it's just an example of connecting
to a library
um
right under the hood how this worked
right so so here's it's a packlet
um and and here's the basic structure of
it so the first thing is I have this
symbol that you know this this string
you know you presume right basically
this is the the path to the the main
libtq which is the postgres client
library and you know presumably you'd
set this path more intelligently than I
have here
um actually one other reason that's kind
of silly
um and hopefully will change soon
um why it's good to do this is that as
opposed to including you know the string
you know
uh you know some string that's on your
library path in every call is that
actually
right now find libraries a bit slow
because it's sort of there's some
caching that it could do but it doesn't
do right now
um and so basically when you call
foreign function load and it and you
don't give it a full path to a library
find libraries taking up like 95 of its
run time
um no right so so here I'm calling find
file once which will always be the most
efficient thing to do maybe when when
there's better sort of caching stuff
it'll be comparable to you know
including it every in every call but
yeah yeah okay in any case though so I I
have this this variable here and then if
we look at like how an actual function
is defined basically I I sort of lazily
load a bunch of foreign functions and I
think it's kind of important that they
be lazily loaded because it means that
you know these don't get loaded it needs
time like you run needs it won't load
anything and that means that both one
needs will be faster because it doesn't
have to load things it doesn't have to
call 55 or find library and so on
um and then second it's also uh
uh uh it's also nice because it means
that for example if you wanted to call
needs and then you for whatever reason
as a user wanted to modify this Library
path then you could do that before it
suddenly starts just loading stuff
so right
um
but yeah but then the basic flow is you
sort of lazily load whatever functions
you want and then you know here's the
top level wrapper function and you can
see you know here I'm loading the main
connect function and here I'm you know
calling it and then it's just a matter
of like well we get back this raw
pointer referring to the connection and
then it's well there's another function
that you give it this this connection
and it tells you the status you know
status ID so then I can just call that
um you know and then I can check it's
correct and so on and if it doesn't work
we can get the error message convert it
to a string and then put it into a
failure object
over here
yeah right so
I mean I I really like the way these
decorations work for the foreign
function load it's very clean I mean you
basically just have to copy that out of
the C like C code
which presumably we could in principle
have
um
uh you know we could in principle have
some technology that would at least take
um
um that that's actually a note I think
Todd suggested this
um I I right so so this is so one
question would be so let me take out an
example here
so uh right so here's what the
Declaration looks like right now but
there's sort of two versions of this
that you could imagine that would bring
it closer to to this you know the
original C that might be useful so the
first thing would be supporting strings
here that look more like C types so
maybe in addition to supporting these
compiler types maybe we could support
something like this
I think that would be a good idea
yeah
right
um yeah and then and then on top of that
if we want to go even even more you
could imagine having a like sort of a
two argument form and this this is a
little sketchier but but maybe we could
do something that just parses it from a
c declaration so you know if you read
the documentation for p q error message
it'll probably look something like this
you know uh a wrong way around but uh
right
so something like that right that that
would be the Declaration so maybe you
can just pass in that and it will pull
out the name and and this is kind of the
one step before reading a header file
yes
but but it's avoiding you know we can be
more restrictive here like it can't you
can't have macros in there and stuff
like that
um I think that will be cool and I don't
see any reason not to be able to do that
right because we can recognize that it's
got parentheses in it you know
well it's also just the two argument
form right this is a two argument form
this is totally distinct from these
other things the the only case that
could be ambiguous is this in the sense
that you know maybe like right maybe
it's ambiguous maybe we have a compiler
type called void but but actually not
lowercase right right lower case the
conventions are such that I think it
should never be a problem
um but it is technically there could be
a collision
maybe foreign function load is
fundamentally a c-based thing that is
all the Declarations uh C type
declarations there's no possibility of
that becoming some Rust declaration or
something which has different
capitalization conventions
well it's it's right it has to be
compatible with the cabi so that
basically means it has to there has to
be a way of representing it with C types
pretty much right like if I if I were to
write a Rest Library which I've done
that exposes a cabi
you know I might want to put a rest type
in there but for all practical purposes
if I'm exposing a cabi I'm going to have
to be generating a c header and at that
point I might as well just copy out the
things from that c header anyway like we
it's not worth adding the complexity of
n more languages parsing to this when C
is like the lingual Franca it's the
common thing
so I don't yeah so I think we should
just do this I think it's really cool
yeah okay that sounds good there's some
there's some subtleties though about
about Pointer variables right like an
instar could be an array of integers or
it could be an out into parameter right
something that's filled in by the
function and there's they're Marshall
very totally differently so there's some
subtlety that we're gonna have to
provide some hinting to uh for for this
for this type of automatic uh generation
because of the memory management around
those things well well just because
there might be different things and in
Star being you have to read the
documentation for a c function and
instantly no you have to know what it is
I mean you can't interest on it right
but but actually I would argue that that
that's right so I mean we talked a
little bit about this before also I mean
this is um for example if this function
returns a Char star you know uh do we
automatically convert that to a string
and if so who owns the memory or do we
assume it's a pointer to a Char or
whatever I think the right answer and
what this sort of tries to do mostly
right now is that it does nothing it
gives you a raw pointer of a Char right
and you're responsible for converting
that and managing the memory of it and
so on because otherwise there's just
lots of magic that has to kind of pop
out
and and realistically you know it's it's
not much
right you're going to need to put
wrappers around these functions anyway
in order to make them sort of nice top
level functions and so it's not hard to
add to that rapper oh buffer to string
or something like that if you want to
return string
I think I understand I mean you know if
if we did have functions that didn't
have to do complex data structure memory
management if it was just you know three
ins going to one inch or something then
it's all very straightforward but as
soon as you have something where there's
memory being managed on one side or the
other it's going to be more complicated
right and you can have like I think I
think toddler again.net link or like an
in.net with their P invoke system there
are ways of like representing here where
you sort of annotate this by saying oh
this is an in-out parameter representing
a string or you know whatever like you
can kind of give a whole representation
of which things are going in where and
what's being Modified by the caller and
and so on but but I think
ultimately I think that system ends up
being kind of complicated and we don't
really have many really natural ways of
like for example if you have a function
that that mutates its arguments we don't
really have any natural way of doing
that in the language anyway
um yeah so yeah
so I mean okay
fine so let me see on the on the left
hand side there
right I mean
in a typical case if we have a large
library and again I wish we had more
examples of all of this
where
well like ref prop for example is an
example of something with a fairly large
Library
I believe with many functions to expose
so it'd be nice to know
oh it has C documentation
well I hope so or high level API that's
probably the Capi
oh no no this is this is Fortran
well okay but there is a I mean you can
see this this is just the thing with
functions with gazillions that describes
things about floppy disks there
um right well
yeah I I can't really comment on this
particular Library
okay
well it'd be nice to see
no I mean why we're not low there we are
okay
right okay but but yeah I mean this is
an example of a library where I don't
think there are complicated data
structures it's just a library where
it's doing crunchy stuff
you know for itself
and then returning fairly simple things
right Honestly though I think something
like this postgres library is more
realistic I mean like this is more like
the kinds of Library connections I've
done like like in openssl it's similar
like you have some functions that create
some objects you kind of need to pass
them around and and you know there's a
function for freeing the objects when
you're done with them and
yeah you're probably right you're
probably right I don't know how many
libraries there are that are like ref
prop they're just pure computation
libraries
anyway okay no matter so okay let's
continue with the design we were looking
at right
yeah so I mean I'm just right maybe I'll
just show one other example thing so so
then you can see uh I mean here's for
example the querying function which is
ultimately similar you know Define a
bunch of foreign functions then put them
into this definition here maybe the
slightly more interesting part would be
like uh
the actual sort of result object uh you
know from from the resulting a query is
really just a wrapper around a pointer
right and a point to that sort of memory
managed that when it's when you stop
referencing this result object it will
it'll free the underlying object and
then you know if you want to query from
it like for example if I want to ask you
know how many columns are in the result
it's just going to call a c function on
that underlying pointer just to return
the result so it's it's quite natural
um
right but I think I think that this is
this is realistically what what code
using this was code looks really quite
clean for what it is I mean I guess I
have one question which is when you're
debugging this what does debugging look
like
uh debugging is honestly really nice
because basically the the way I would
debug it was uh well first of all I can
just run these in an interactive session
especially if I export this variable I
can just run this in this session here
and then I can try calling any of these
underlying functions and otherwise
everything is just in the top level so
it's you know it's just debugging
occasionally the kernel crashes with the
front end survives
yeah sure right you can if you do
something if you do something dangerous
yes you could have definitely crashed
things but that's fine but we have
pretty good apparatus for that because
we've still got all your definitions you
just rerun them you fix it you rerun
them it's all good if you have a deeper
version of the library you can also
attach a debugger to the kernel and then
debug in the library
what does that look like ux wise
well I mean it looks like you know ask
Microsoft or or apple I mean you're
running xcode or you're running visual
studio so you have another window so you
have the notebook window up you're
running yeah I mean I I do that I do
that sort of thing all the time
fair enough
that's your your you know we don't make
a sea level debug no no obviously we
shouldn't no I understand that but I
mean I'm saying there are two there are
two windows on the screen one is yeah
yeah I get it absolutely yeah
but that's okay that's fine
all right
well so I guess the main design I mean
this looks about as clean as it could be
the stuff on the left in terms of what
you know
right
in terms of cleannesses this is this is
the main outstanding design question
okay which is that there are a couple of
these sort of helper functions the only
one I'm really calling here is this
buffer to string one that that are kind
of uh you know needed to to manipulate
the the inputs and outputs of these
things
um and which you know okay so show us
the complete collection of these guys
right so here here's all the functions
so the main ones are these ones that
talk about buffer right so basically
these are all functions that do things
like taking pointers and turning them
into Strings or taking strings and
turning them into pointers
okay so there's also callback we haven't
talked about callback have we
uh no actually we haven't but it's it's
relatively straightforward but yeah we
can call back first and then let's talk
about buffers
okay well I don't have an example of a
callback set up here although I could
get one actually I think I have well
don't you have documentation for
callback
uh it's kind of out of date actually no
sorry I do have a documentation for
callback
um
yes give me just a moment
right now I actually was there
is this passing a function into the
library to be called
uh yes yes
um
I believe I have an example if I
um oh this is not a good way to there's
much better ways of getting to this
so just a moment
right so here's an example I had
similarly connecting to sqlite using the
same kind of mechanism
and um
okay it's working so yeah so here I'm
just gonna quickly this is some of this
code has actually been simplified a bit
and can be uh can be made a bit cleaner
now but
um right so I'm just gonna run this okay
so here's here's an example of the
Callback mechanism so there's a function
called sqlite exec
and you can sort of see what it does
here this is the C you know
Declaration of it so you give it sort of
a pointer the database that's an opaque
pointer you give it a string as a Char
star a query and then you give it a
callback function
and basically this callback function
gets fed a bunch of random stuff that
basically represents the Callback so I
think the important stuff is this is the
number of columns in the result
um and then this is you know an array of
strings with you know wherever for each
column it gives you the name of the
column and this one is an array of
strings where each for each column it
gives you the value of that column and
it'll call this callback for every Row
in the result
um okay so so for example here if I have
let's see I'm going to make this
database object so here's a a DB which
is just represented with this managed
pointer so basically right I called the
the internal open function it returns an
opaque raw pointer I then used create
managed expression to tell it basically
when you're done with this thing call
sqlite close on it and that's just the
sqlite function for closing a database
and so that that's what this object is
here we need to maybe talk a little bit
about
uh maybe some naming with this and also
uh whether they're ways in certain cases
of of having this happen by by default
but but okay
so now if I want to actually uh
right so here I can actually you know
call it in this case feeding it a null
pointer for its uh for its callback and
it works but it doesn't really do
anything very exciting alternatively
um you can yeah it has a special case if
you give it another pointer it doesn't
call it so I'm not doing something that
dangerous by doing that otherwise
basically here what I've done is I'm
making this callback object where
basically I'm telling it I'm giving it a
top level function which this could be
any I mean this could be F but like I'm
just giving it's something that will
print and and I'm giving it a type
signature and that's this type signature
exactly this one right here
yep
um and then uh if I actually run this
thing you see it would be very nice if
you could just copy that type signature
from up above and stick it in there yeah
well that's kind of what we just talked
about yeah not being C type signatures
yeah so you would be able to
um
but but right but so in any case though
if I run this you can see it printed
twice once for each result hold on hold
on hold on still internalizing what this
actually did so you you pass simple
callback which is
that is effectively a function pointer
just as just as the Declaration there is
a function pointer this is very nice
Christopher I haven't seen this
there is a function there is a function
being created that's being sent in no no
I understand that but I'm thinking about
the Declaration up above the C
declaration up above is asking for a
pointer to a callback function and this
is now delivering that callback function
simple callback what is the value of
simple callback that thing that's
wrapped as a as a callback there is some
kind of is is basically wrapping a raw
function pointer is that correct
basically Yes actually there's this one
little piece of complication about it
which is that
um right so so the one piece of
complication is that uh
right so ultimately this callback when
you pass it into a function gets inter
it gets unwrapped and all that the
function sees is the function pointer
however there's a bit of extra memory
associated with it so when you actually
create a callback it has to allocate
these like little regions in memory that
the function pointer points to and as
long as that function pointer is being
used you have to keep that memory
allocated right because otherwise it's
going to point to nothing
um and so uh there's actually a function
that's called I think I call it delete
callback I saw that yeah right and so
and so here what I made this one kind of
being
leaked or or you could say this is what
you'd want to do if you want to make a
callback pass it to some external
library and then you want to throw away
your own reference to the Callback and
just have it live forever and that
external Library can always call it this
is how you would do that if you wanted
to make a callback that you knew was not
going to live on forever in that
external library then you would use like
a a managed a managed thing so right now
the way you do that is you say oops
you'd say create managed expression of
create callback comma delete callback
right and this would make a uh a managed
object for you but why do we need a
special function for deleting a callback
right I mean
right because I had some extra memory
well I don't know why does the Callback
need to be deleted and why do we need a
function with the word callback in its
name for deleting callbacks
surely object yeah delete object or even
have we know it's a callback if there's
anything special to be done we know what
to do but there might not even be
anything special to be done maybe this
is just a call for free right okay so
maybe maybe it is delete objects so
there's a couple um I think that that
could work there's a couple of delete
functions here
and they maybe could all be delete
object okay it's delete buffer and
delete callback
okay that's that's the more common
question
name okay so you're saying create
callback but I think the name of the
Callback thing should be at best you
know callback function callback object I
don't think it should just be called
callback it's obscure what that means
sure
what do you think it should be called
callback object I think callback to
object is fine yeah I mean some of these
other things I don't use the object like
managed expression it's just managed
expression function
well but it's not a function like you
can't you can't uh maybe there could be
a sub value for this but but this
doesn't do anything
this is obvious way man could that do
something well actually no it shouldn't
because it like for example you can do
that right or like I think that gives
you the function pointer right it has so
it has access there so yeah this should
honest print a message or something but
yeah okay
what is the Callback what's the delete
thing doing is it just freeing up the
expression no it's freeing that it's
freeing that the memory that the
function pointer points to
when you make the function pointer you
have to allocate some memory you know
that that represents that contains the
actual code that the function pointer
points to why why why why can't you do
that automatically
because you don't know if if you might
allocate that and then you know you
might create a callback and then pass it
to some external library or pass the
function pointer to some external
library and then you might throw away
your callback object in the top level
but that function pointer lives on in
that external Library forever
and so that you know in that case maybe
maybe the external Library if it wants
to hang on to it it should do some sort
of acquire type of thing
that would prevent this is a different
model for memory management right so one
model is basically the you know you
create it and then you free it the other
is you know you create it and then you
increment its reference count and
decrement its reference count I think so
far everything here has been just you
know there's
we haven't provided any direct access to
reference counts we either just have you
create it and you free it and worst case
if you want to reference count something
use managed expression and then it's you
know you know the reference count is
kind of opaque maybe we could add some
sort of acquire and and you know release
mechanism to manage expressions
um
that that might make some sense I think
that's how you would do that
hey I got a simple suggestion you've got
an address in the pick rule pointer I
mean at least in my life in using
debuggers those things are always in HEX
yeah that could be in that's a pain
though it's it's real pain you're right
yeah
it's base form right yeah yeah
that's input yeah
and you know I never remember which
comes first yeah that can make some
sense maybe we give it in base form of
the sub 16 there and that way if you
paste it you you could do that the right
thing
so zero X or something in front of it
yeah yeah well we got sub 16 that's our
version of zero X
we're pandering to the hex hexing of the
whole thing
um an important demographic for us
indeed the um
okay
so okay so let's go back to the Callback
thing so then
callback object otherwise this looks
fine although and then a delete object
on the Callback object
right
so maybe this is
well so sorry were you gonna say
something yeah I just wanted to ask a
minor question about like do we think
the word callback or callback object
sounds a bit more General than how it's
being used here because I could conceive
of a world where callback is something
that's used for like I've Cloud deployed
something and it makes a callback to my
local machine or something I can see
that too
well what's a better term I mean I could
say foreign callback I don't know just
for consistency I'm not sure
what is this callback really it's a
callback
I agree that foreign callback does sound
more sensible
right so basically what it is is it's
basically Library callback a function uh
sure although I I think it's foreign is
better than Library based on the
conventions we have basically what it
represents it represents a function
pointer that
that that basically was created by the
language and whose purpose is to call a
wolf from language you know evaluate
some more from language I think foreign
callback is the right name for it
right fine and the foreign callback
object would be its object name
so create foreign callback
could we imagine the library callback
and I'm not saying we should do this but
Library link could support something
like that for passing similar callbacks
it's less important because in library
Lake is pretty easy to trigger an
evaluation so you can use other
mechanisms through the there's like a
callback link object
um so it's not strictly necessary to
have something like this but anyway
all right okay let's move on so are we
ready to look at buffers now yes yes and
buffers are the probably the more
complicated one so okay here here's the
basic deal there's a whole bunch of
different objects that you can convert
two buffers a bunch of objects you can
convert from buffers
um there's a lot of overlap
like for example all of the two buffer
functions you know they take this object
and they just return some raw pointer
thing what um what is a buffer
a buffer okay buffer here has just been
my term for a pointer
um and maybe I should be using the term
pointer but uh maybe I'll explain why I
didn't in a moment so for example if I
say you know string to buffer
of you know hello
there's a raw pointer and now I could do
something like if I if I loaded uh
string you know sterlen I could call it
on this and it would it would work
um
so okay so basically what it's doing is
it's taking one of our types so in a
sense it's like like when we say export
byte array or something you you know
export byte array takes whatever thing
we have and turns it into a byte array
here what you're doing is you're taking
something like a string and you're
turning it into a a piece of memory
instead of it being ordinary export will
you know spit out a file in the file
system
another externally managed thing the
file system so I'm I'm going to make a
claim that a possible name for this
would be you know export
something like
uh you know just like we have export
byte array will be something like export
foreign export
buffer export raw pointer export
something like that I mean the
yeah yeah so so let me explain maybe two
of the other problems here so so is it
the first the first maybe this isn't a
problem but the first thing is that
right now all these two a lot of two
buffer functions could be merged right
so it's pretty unambiguous if I give you
a string what you should do if I give
you a list if I give you a numeric array
you don't really need me to you know I
we could just I might have to give the
native type you might have to give the
native type of the
so this isn't it right so here's here's
here's the example so list to buffer
right
right now you need to tell it you know
it's a c int or something or it's uh you
know limit the CN staw
uh well this is the this is the argument
type element the element type yeah
element type yeah yeah
um quick quick question strain to buffer
is that utf-8 or the RM utf-8 variant or
yeah so this is this is not utf-8 and it
needs a character encoding or it's using
whatever the the internal the internal
Unicode representation that's kind of
crazy it maybe should use the same utf-8
thing it should use utf-8 by default
right that's crazy total thing is
crazy I recently learned that string to
byte array is documented to use utf-8
unless you tell it otherwise which I
think makes me think this should just
use utf-8 yeah yeah definitely
um
but but it needs right this is one of
the cases I was going to bring up so
list of buffer you need to know the type
string to buffer might need to know the
character encoding so this is the small
areas where there isn't overlap
um
right so that there are small
differences between these but it might
be possible to coerce them into one well
I mean it's just like with Import and
Export we have all kinds of elements and
special options for different import
export types right so maybe you could do
something like this so two buffer of you
know hello this this would work then
maybe uh you know this would tell you
that you need to give it a second
argument
um maybe this you know you can you can
give it C Char and if you give it
anything other than c Char or something
equivalent it'll complain and this is
also used to focus like one of the other
ones is numerical Rays numerical Rays
you can technically determine the size
from from this the second argument here
but honestly I think it's better if
you're forced to to do it again or like
if you at least have the option to
because these things are are very
automatic like you see here it just
decided you know based on the arguments
what type to do so I think it's bad to
rely on on that
um
so what would it do if you specify a
smaller size than what size the numeric
Ray actually has
uh I think it'll attempt to cast it
using the compiler's mechanism for
downcasting a numeric array and if it
fails it'll fail
okay so it won't silently truncate or I
don't know clip or
saturated or any other things
well I think the compiler actually
checks it by default is like safe it'll
do a safe cast and it will it'll
complain I think
um right this is the kind of thing
that's subtle enough that I think
complaining is the right Behavior like
you should yeah you should be forced to
get this right right
we could support something like the
method option for numeric array where
you see that's a whole bunch of things
but for now
it doesn't seem super important so
really I agree I agree okay so let's go
back to the naming I mean I'm I'm
claiming export to buffer or something
or okay
okay so something like that
right and they will be presumably import
from buffer would be the other way
okay and so then now maybe it's just
export buffer import buffer
foreign
export yeah I think that makes some
sense so so you'd have um you know goes
with import buffer and presumably so
import buffers are more complicated
because it is ambiguous so presumably
I'd give it some you know
uh raw pointer of blah blah blah and
then what do I do I tell it I want back
what a list I want back a string I want
you know how do I specify we have a
bunch of functions that have things like
this well you yes I mean that's exactly
what import elements do right
I'm trying to think if there are any
cases where you need to parametrize this
as well I guess I'm sure there is
oh length yeah that's an obvious one
sorry yes almost right so a lot of them
need to know the the length it's a
string can infer length if you let if
you let it assume it's zero null
terminated otherwise you know you need
to be able to
has all kinds of stuff in it
third argument I guess if the second
argument is always needed which is the
type
The Destination type right that the
second argument is like the import
element it's the Destination type
yeah one thing I might say is that well
right I think this is probably the right
thing maybe it should have like an
operator form or something though
because I I'd say this is super common
like like for example this buffered a
string thing where it's just I call this
function it returns a Char star just
just assumes it's all terminated and
give me a string and I think it's kind
of nice to be able to do these like nice
short things like this but I guess we
could do that with a
you know
uh something like that
does that work what I see because it's a
one argument form right the one argument
form yeah is the type
it could even technically work like this
right because it can tell this isn't a
pointer this is
you know the first argument I would
claim that 10.
okay so okay
all these things what what type are they
if I pass one of these things into a
compiled function
what type would it have
you mean this raw pointer thing well the
output of two buffer
right so this is a good this is a good
question okay so this is this is the
reason I'm using the term buffer and not
pointer which is a little inconsistent
okay so so this is um it's okay you see
if I call this to buffer it returns a
raw pointer right now there are two
objects that I have right now I have raw
pointers and opaque crop pointers
they're the same thing except raw
pointers also contain information about
the type that they point to so no pay
crop pointer is basically a void star
um
right so the reason okay so there's a
little complication here the compiler
has these same exact types it has opegra
pointer and raw pointer and they're kind
of working in the same way right now
those types have no automatic expression
conversion because we thought maybe we
should and maybe they should and maybe
they should convert to this right yeah
yeah that would be great I think that
would be kind of interesting yeah yeah
so so I think I think that makes some
sense the only place I mean I mean I
think if we can use the word raw pointer
that has to happen
okay so so now the question is otherwise
we use a different name right okay yes I
I agree I agree with that so the
question is though for the buffer
functions the reason I call them buffer
and not pointer or something like that
is because right now in the compiler
there are these two functions
um two raw pointer and from raw pointer
which do things that are are
well okay from raw pointer actually has
a close analog to some of these buffer
functions from raw pointer is either
equivalent to some some kind of uh
import from buffer or some kind actually
I think it's well yeah with the load
it's it's reading it's loading from the
address right so two raw pointed out
really doesn't have an analog here
because two raw pointer can do things
like stack allocation which is just
meaningless here all right so the
allocator does two raw points or just do
the equivalent of Ampersand and C
well there's a couple things so to our
pointer several usages actually there
might they might even be documented
um okay so so let's go from the bottom
to the top because because I think this
is the easiest to understand so the
first one is basically
um you give it it's something like this
like the first the first one is
basically equivalent to uh uh you know
array you know or R of I equals
right that's what the last one is it's
basically for for inserting values into
arrays where the representatives are
Pointers the next one is basically star
I or Star P equals X
so basically I have a value and I want
to store it in this pointer
uh that's a very weird thing for a thing
called two two raw pointer to do and I
would expect two roll points to just be
like an ampersand operation well it's
putting it on no no because I'm just
saying only doesn't exist
so so yeah actually I I remember this is
the equivalents are all written in here
so the issue is that Ampersand is kind
of it actually doesn't make any sense
for Ampersand to exist Ampersand is kind
of a c language feature that is kind of
incoherent outside of C you could only
you can't Supply the Ampersand to
everything you can't apply it to like a
number or something it has to be to a to
an identifier so
right so so these are the the real
equivalents so two raw pointer open
closer of a value basically I think
these things are not bad actually I I
think they they've held up quite nicely
I think
yeah I yeah but but the point is though
that this thing is doing if you see this
it's doing a stack allocation and then
it's populating it yeah that is not what
this is doing this doesn't do stack
allocations
um and it's important for the semantics
of two raw pointer that it's a stack
allocation that you don't have to free
it and so on yes
um
so right it's a reasonable name for a
thing that is sitting out there as a
piece of memory that you would have to
do something to
okay fine well maybe one other case
maybe just worth mentioning because I
kind of forgot it but it's listed here
so I also have what is it what are some
synonyms for buffer because buffer has
this implication that it's for Io
which this isn't necessarily I mean what
else could it be great
well array is another one but that's
that's not a good allocated memory
I mean it's it's what it represents is a
chunk of memory yeah
single objective 10 objects who knows
it's just a foreign memory for an object
foreign
well hold on I mean the usages you were
describing seemed like they were very
closely tied to the idea of the sequence
of things like to have the fact that the
length argument is in there or that what
you're specifying is an element type
so it's more generic than a pointer
certainly
well actually it says this is the thing
that I was trying to get to is that
there's there's actually two other
functions there's populate buffer and
d-reference buffer which are basically
for so all these other functions I've
shown like the you know uh string to
buffer numerical right these are all
about buffers that point to arrays right
but but sometimes either a you want to
be able to point to individual elements
of arrays or B you have an individual
object and there's no array involved
it's just a pointer to it an inch or
something like that a single int and and
that's what populate buffer and
dereference buffer for and that those
I'm not sure exactly what the analog
would be with this import thing I have
to think about it for a moment hold on
what do those do again
so actually you know I wonder if I've
done the name buffer is really bad if
it's a single object I mean that gets
really kind of crazy
I mean I I kind of like the idea of the
name Memory it's pretty clear that well
we're dealing with this memory it could
be a sequence of things it could not be
a sequence of things
I find a little odd about the what you
have here like the distinction we didn't
populate buffer dereference buffer and
then the other ones that operate on list
like things is that they're making
something that is kind of part of a type
into two separate apis like list like
things and scalar things
and that seems like to be better
represented just at the type level
why isn't this like called raw memory
just like you have a raw pointer you
could have a raw memory
yeah and draw pointers represent raw
memory
yeah rule pointers point to role that's
not bad that's not bad so wait let me um
up here raw memory so instead what we'd
have okay let me see here so we'd have
import raw memory
and uh and Export raw memory
yeah
actually I should write that here
that's pretty descriptive
yeah I like that actually
so how would you represent like what
would be the type for list like things
versus scalar like things and if you're
doing import raw memory of a list like
thing where do you specify the length
right so let's let's maybe just go
through the cases because there aren't
that many right so if we look at or let
me um sorry just a moment
okay so first let's get all of the the
two buffer
we shall we like Import and Export it's
more like two raw memory and from raw
members yeah it might not be important
export might not be right yeah
okay well let's let's let's start with
Import and Export and then we can we can
play around okay so if we're going to
have a single export raw memory function
all right so so list to buffer
right right now this takes a list and it
takes the element type
so now this would turn into what would
it turn into one two three and then what
would it be you know list
like that
thinking I mean
so that's
of a list
well what wouldn't it be
why not use the compiler like the colon
yeah specifier
well list is not a compiler type so it
makes sense
I mean it's it's right there it is a
list
what else would it be oh that's okay so
maybe this returns a list
uh well okay now here's a question
though so so what about the I was going
to get to this one later what about the
the um uh populate buffer
okay or so sorry I have one just called
create buffer that I think uh does this
operation so
um right so this is uh
right this could personally be create or
allocate raw memory
um
oh I think this this is out of date
um but but basically the idea is uh
right so suppose I have the number 12
and I want to make a pointer to 12. yeah
you have to allocate rule memory of 12.
right but how is that
well first there's the case of I want to
allocate just a buffer like a
quote-unquote empty buffer of you know
12 integers or actually different
numbers you know a bunch of integers
um
I'm not sure that's the right way around
though I would have thought it was like
CNT how do you specify that as a
compiler type you want to
you do create type instance
of C array
of CN with length 1512 okay
so create type instance has a second
argument which is a length it has it has
the first argument is the type and all
the other arguments are type specific
okay all right okay so allocate role
memory
but now how is allocate okay so so this
this is allocating basically
uninitialized memory and Export is for
allocating initialized memory
but now the only weird thing is if we if
we want to do the case of if we support
this presumably then this is the way of
getting a pointer to the number 12 right
yes
you know I guess it's it's a little
weird I guess it's actually okay
these are equivalent right this is these
are actually mean the same thing
I've got one more case for you you want
to allocate a a array of length of a
thousand but you're only filling in two
elements how do you do that I think you
allocate it yourself and then you use
something like populate buffer yeah yeah
to to point the the populate buffer is
basically the the lower level you know
um you know right
populate role memory
oh wait Connor you were just suggesting
right raw memory right I think it's more
more yeah
hold on let me write these down though
um so we'd have um populate buffer goes
to right raw memory and then what would
dereference buffer be which is the the
analysis yeah
write and read I mean
yeah I think that makes sense
and it makes it clear this is an unsafe
operation like you know danger you will
crash your kernel if you ask for an
element that doesn't exist or something
um
okay what about can you actually read
real memory of a raw hexadecimal address
yeah of course but but it might it might
explode it might seg fault yeah I
understand but how do you do that do you
just give the the rule read raw memory
of raw pointer of I see
the number
and then uh and then this representably
assume that this is just a pointer to a
c Char and presumably then this would
assume it's an array of C chars and it's
going to give you the fourth element and
uh and maybe you can do something like
you know I'm sorry what was it this is
four what does that mean I thought we're
giving that means this is an array of C
chars because a pointer you don't know
if it's a pointer to a single element or
an array no I get it right so this
assumes it's the rain we're getting the
fourth element
um
fourth is a is an offset isn't it well
okay this doesn't right this is a good
question part number you see it from raw
pointer we made the kind of agonizing
decision
which I'm still not sure either way
whether it was right but the second
argument is an offset which starts at
zero as opposed to an index which starts
at one
yeah go ahead well the argument for
being an offset is that it would be more
like from raw pointer and it's very C
like the argument for being index is I
like if you want to have something like
a span I I'm not comfortable having an
offset in a span right right
um yes
and I think having stuff like a span
could be quite useful what about
negative
indices
but you don't know how long it is
okay yeah you know one thing I realized
that is a sign of age in general
whatever the point is that you get back
here I was thinking these are really
long pointers and I realized I haven't
used a raw debugger since 64-bit that
yeah
um but we don't have 128-bit machines
yet so right
the uh okay
I think it has to be an offset I I think
it's too weird
we're dealing with memory
I kind of think it has to be offset as
well yeah we have other things we have
that that are labeled from zero we have
um bits so we have a zeroth bit
we don't have a first bit and what
well in numbers
so they have a zeroth bit
do we have a function that gets you the
zeroth bit well we talk about yeah you
know if we get extra digits yeah
yeah
do we have anything that's like an
operator form of a part specification
that people could use if they really
wanted to
extract I always wonder if take had a
you know take doesn't that yeah I think
extract mind
yeah extract does
yeah so you could do extract of an index
or presumably a span Works two or up two
and all the others why look that that
span could just be a list here because a
list this is a pure one-dimensional
object this is not multi-dimensional
memory right so maybe maybe it takes
essentially a take spec so it takes
three seven or three eight and then you
know we could do maybe this takes every
second yeah I think so I think it takes
it takes back of offsets
right
and you don't want to get the third the
eighth and the second
thing you want to get upset three eight
and two what well actually that's a good
question if I all right does does this
get you offsets three through eight or
does this get you offsets three and
eight
three three is this a spanner list
I think it's a list I mean I think it's
a span
and if you want the other thing then you
put them in sub lists
fine
okay yeah is this supported by okay so
I'll just look at what take does I'll
just emulate what take does because take
already has this list uh MN yes
um
it's a take spec so if this is a take
spec
on the other hand the four is not to
take specs the four would get you the
fourth element so there's a bit of
confusion here
that's true
yeah and I think it's useful for that
you know I guess you could do that
but it feels a bit bad
or what's more useful I mean or is it in
fact the case that you often want to get
the whole array
or actually take doesn't even support
this I think you have to give it like
this
or no that's fine no no that's melted no
way to do it yeah no way to do it right
yeah so maybe
take specs are not the thing then
okay but hold on is this okay read rule
memory there's a question of how the
offset works
what other things do we have to solve
here
you mean in general or yeah in general
for for redrawal memory right memory is
that more stuff to sell or so yes so so
there's one big thing to solve which is
anything that generates
a pointer
the question is does it generate a
managed one by default so right now if
you call you know create buffer any of
these any of these functions right uh I
don't even remember what this takes but
okay there we go it returns a raw
pointer and now this is a memory leak if
you don't free it yourself so it's very
common so for example if I call string
to buffer myself
you know it's very common that you you
have to put this around it before you
really do anything with it
um
the question is maybe these should
return a managed one by default and then
there's an option where you can say
something like you know
management yeah goes to false
um what's the thing for borrowing don't
we have a thing for extracting
there's two ways to borrow the first
thing is that if I have a managed
expression
um if I pass it into to uh you know a
form function it'll automatically unwrap
it which is effectively borrowing
um otherwise you can always just ask for
you know the or I think it's called
expression actually you can always ask
for the payload there's actually I
shouldn't get into this but there's a
little bit of subtlety about the
expression versus the payload which are
almost always the same but they can be
different
because basically we have things for
basic casting pointers so for example if
you have a raw pointer and you want to
make it opaque or if you have an opaque
pointer and you want to annotate it with
a type you can always just say Okay crop
pointer of a raw point or like for
example if I wanted to say you think
this is a pointer to integrates but it's
actually a pointer to integer 64s right
which is a common thing you want to sort
of especially because functions like
read raw memory they look at the type
that this is pointing to that's why you
don't have to tell it what type it is so
the point is if I say raw pointer of
this managed object
and I tell it actually you're a pointer
to an integer 64. you see that now the
value has has changed and so now
everything will treat the segment
integer 64. but critically the
payload is still the original one
because basically there there can only
ever be one
there can only ever be one underlying
managed object right like you have to it
has to know because you don't want to
call free more than once
whatever this is kind of a subtle thing
right yeah let's come back to by the way
in the in the create managed expression
why is delete object as it would now be
not the default second argument if you
only give one argument
um maybe it should be yeah
um
let me think about that for a moment so
let me well first let me make a note so
create managed expression could default
to delete object so the only minor
concern I would have is that you can
only use delete object on it if it's
something that we made right so it might
look like an opaque draw pointer but if
it didn't come from you know allocate
raw memory if it actually came from
postgres you better not you know you
better not call delete object on it
because that'll crash
um don't we know
like I I don't think there's any if you
just have a pointer I don't think
there's any real good way of knowing
whether you know whether it'll crash
when you try and free it no well
although we presumably if we actually
have this as a symbolic object it could
have tagging inside the symbolic object
that says I was created by if you're
literally passing it unchanged from one
place to another it could maintain
tagging of whether we created it
um let me think about that so the idea
is that the single argument form of
create managed expression would only
work if you applied it to the sort of
unchanged results yes of you know uh
I'm thinking about that it it does seem
a little magic
um
well it can tell you that the magic you
know that there wasn't enough magic if
it wasn't there it'll just give you an
error message it'll tell you right
argument the the alternative though to
be clear the alternative would be that
all these functions like allocate memory
and raw memory and so on just by default
give you a managed one well if you ask
for an unmanaged one in which case you
know you would need that
which seems somewhat sensible for them
to do it by default right most the time
you want a managed one but you do need
the option to make an unmanaged one
and I think it'll be pretty obvious now
I think about it you know if you look at
how this displays
it's pretty darn obvious it's giving you
something that's memory managed
um yes
so I mean because an alternative design
which I had some I I considered by I I
sort of didn't do would be that you have
all this memory management information
inside of the raw pointer so all you see
is raw pointer and it has some little
indication I think by the way I'm a
managed one
right yeah minor comment I think given
if the freeing function is usually
delete object you could elide it in the
case where so that you have a more
beautiful looking managed expression
blob
um pointer
yes just to make it look nicer I mean
it's not super you know the main thing
you get from that is
it's managed it's a certain type and
there's a meaningless piece of hex
let me let me just um
allocate so okay allocate raw memory and
friends you know
return managed
uh right managed expressions
so
right what would now yeah and then the
only times when it's a different frame
function it's okay I think that usually
the freeing function is delete object
for relatively short-lived things the
thing is that where it has different
printing function is like for example if
I look at
if I go way up here
um
right if we look at this postgres
connection okay so I have this this Con
so let's see what this actually has
inside of it the input form will be a
little bit broken right now but um
right so so if we look at
so basically the first argument is just
uh
or actually right well let me just get
the managed expression out okay so here
it is so we've got a pointer and the
freeing function is this EQ finish which
is a you know
the postgres function for free you know
closing a connection
um this is super typical
um
but but yeah so this is something where
it created there is a complex data
structure created by essentially in a
foreign
function
and yeah it needs a foreign function to
free the foreign created thing
makes sense
all right so what about so the option to
tell it what is it is it memory
management
I would think so
well let's see managed expression uh
yeah I think that's reasonable name
okay
um
let me uh
one other relationship to some compiler
stuff there's a function
yeah there's an experimental function
called unmanage object
so there's kind of an a a very an
analogous type in the compiler that's
analogous to its managed expression
that's just called managed
and basically it you know you it's very
similar so you create right now you
create one by saying create type
instance of managed comma you know your
value comma the freeing function
I think that if we had something like
this managed expression mechanism it
might be worth unifying it with this so
maybe in the compiler you would write
this yeah that sort of thing
yeah
um the term expression might be a little
bit wrong I mean it's not literally an
expression but in instance
I mean it could be object
yep cool yeah and then this could be a
managed object as well then instead of
managed expression I think yeah
I mean fully more fully it will be
Memory managed object
and perhaps it should be so people don't
get confused
um
let me think about that so other than it
being a little bit verbose
I was going to mention I find the
managed name like I know it has a long
history like it's part of Library link
too but it it's just very unintuitive
what managed means I get it you know
I mean it's not even unintuitive it's
just unclear
what about changing the name managed
expression to memory managed
as a rapper
and then what would it be create memory
managed objects
after we create memory managed
which is a bit weird
I mean is memory managed object really
that long
maybe it is it's not that long it's so
it's long but it's you know it's not
something you'd be typing all the time
yeah well it is
this is a pretty this is a function that
you commonly kind of throw in right
after a function call
like like you see that here um if I go
back to my connect function
right you see it right there
just thrown in
and that's very typical right like I
create this thing I check that it's
correct now that I know it's correct
wrap it up so that it will be freed when
it's done
I see
what if we had a memory object type with
an optional managed
option
well that would be the Assistant two two
points here so one one point is that
that's a little bit like the raw pointer
that knows that it's memory managed
I I still think
I think it is different though because a
pointer is is like a pointer is a
lightweight thing if it's a pointer
right but if we had a memory object I
feel like it's a little they have a
little bit more what is the memory
object as opposed to Raw memory I mean
raw memory is
I I also think though that this managed
the managed expression is more General
like I think this the managed expression
honestly you can use outside of ffi
stuff although I don't think it's
terribly useful like you could use it
for you know uh I'm opening a file
stream and I want to make sure that it
gets closed when I'm done with it like
this thing is object
because because if it isn't if it
applies to things that aren't memory
then it's just managed object
yeah
it is more General than memory it's just
that's the the most obvious use case
I mean can we think of names up along
along the lines of like cleaned up
object obviously not that there's like
Mana cleanup we've got the function with
cleanup for something completely
different well it's not completely
different it's very similar actually
well this would be a self self cleaning
object whatever it is
hygienic object hygienica
is there is there a term for this term
like this behavior in cats
well there's hygienic uh macros so
[Music]
I I don't think this is a very serious
no yeah no but I I do think like manage
is just it's just too generic of a word
like it sounds like it's doing all kinds
of fancy stuff when all it does is call
a function when the object goes out of
scope well another reason object maybe
or did technology
right okay I want to leave that vague
and scoped I think also makes it sound
like when it leaves one scope but it
might it might exist in a more scope
yeah I mean no good yeah
collectible object
s like a baseball card or something just
just type in Auto cleaned
will be Auto
clean I'm not sure cleaned is the right
word
Auto deleted Auto cleanup Auto freed
well but again it's not necessarily
deleted it's just when the things
reference count goes to zero it will
call this function on the payload
well we say on free in compiler callback
s
what how does
what semantics of with clean up
it's to do with exceptions
with cleanup just says that this thing
okay first middle cleanup right yeah
yeah or just middle cleanup yeah
okay so I've never totally been sure the
first one's completely necessary but
yeah I think it's I think it's it's
there I think it's because the person
it's like exception it's exception
immune and some terrifying way
um but if it throws an exception you
could just put a semicolon instead of
that first comma and it would no I don't
think so because of the exception
handling
yeah I think the problem is that if you
if you do well yeah yeah that first is
like a critical section type thing
Yeah Yeah a different topic okay but the
basic point is that what this is doing
is just like with cleanup
this is a wrapper for something which is
an auto cleanup type thing actually it
is like abort protects around first with
a semicolon I think that is exactly what
it is that's probably right yeah
okay I mean the most common use case
here is memory management but as you're
saying there's an auto cleanup
just type in Auto cleanup
it's a bit weird
yeah yeah
I know that the front end
well what is this I mean in like um
what do people call this resource and C
plus plus resource acquisition is
initialization is that the acronym
all right
initialization is acquisition is the
other way around right so there were
around
it's raii resource acquisition is
initialization but in the implicit you
know when it's dropped
um
that's something
um what about like something like
destructed or just with Destructor
sounds
dangerous yeah
but remember to be honest it is to do
with memory management because it is
when the expression reference counts
yeah is it reference counted
the expression is reference counted
actually I I don't think we want to
commit to that that's an implementation
feature
yeah right or the compiler where it
could be confident about when to
deallocate something yeah yeah maybe it
would yeah exactly
foreign
well I have to say managed object to me
I mean Conor doesn't like managed but
I just think this is like a concept
that's
yeah but it's also it's a concept that
so many people are familiar with from
like so many other languages managed
seems like an unnecessarily unfamiliar
term is it well manage is used by
Microsoft right for years and years and
years to distinguish between like the
Sea unmanaged World of C C plus plus in
the manage world.net right so people who
are familiar with the Microsoft
Technology stack the word managed is
very understandable
yeah
I think also memory management is like
the general term for a garbage
collection or NRC or yeah I think so
right
so so I think if we're calling it
managed object though the one kind of
question is is this this function which
I guess we could support although I
think it would be marginally useful in
the top level essentially what this does
it does something honestly a little bit
weird and I sort of maybe question it a
little bit basically what it does is it
is it it you give it a managed object
and it gives you back the value inside
that object and then it invalidates the
managed object so that object will no
longer be automatically freed but that
might be useful Christopher like you
pass it you might want to do that
and it would save you from coming to
keep a reference around to the
expression you know might be I mean it
might be handy
actually okay I guess I guess that's
true you probably do need a way of doing
this like otherwise there'd be no if you
have a managed object and you want to
say actually I don't want you to free
this one reference count goes to zero
there's nothing you can do right now you
already set the fuse okay fine so
actually this makes a lot of sense it
blows up unmanaged objectives okay
actually okay because because here's the
thing the original purpose of this
function was this was the way you get
the value out but really maybe the
purpose of this function is this is the
way you you put out the fuse and and it
happens to give you the object out as
well but maybe we can have another
function like borrow managed object or
something that just gives you the value
yeah yeah why isn't the sub value of
managed object right now for the managed
office to use the sub value in the
compiler
it could be actually in the compiler
could be a sub value too it could be
yeah yeah right now it's if you just say
value
all right have we have we basically come
to the end of what we need to do right
now or always
um I think we have let me just quickly
look at this let's talk some more next
week Christopher I'd like to discuss
like yeah now the compiler with this
actually so you know I think actually we
hit everything so another point of queue
is something I haven't seen before in
your list
yeah that one I added recently I that
was kind of on a whim but I think it is
actually a useful object I have to
believe that's useful in other words
you're weirdly going and digging inside
and looking for zeros and things which
is crazy yeah right
yeah okay there is a little bit of
relationship to some uh compiler stuff
like if you want to have like I had a
use case where I had some foreign
functions but then I wanted to compile a
little program that used the foreign
functions but I think there's actually
an obvious uh there's an obvious uh
design for that which is yeah I'd like
to talk about that Christopher maybe we
could talk about that in more detail
yeah sure sure but I think this this
should
this should work right where it just
pulls out the function pointer from this
or actually or it pulls out the library
name and everything that needs from that
yeah I'd like to this is a true
statement that with all this foreign
function stuff you know back in the day
I used to write C programs use template
files call them through math link
is it the case that with all of this
that technology that's irrelevant I can
just make a c
yes yeah I think so and it'll be way
more efficient yeah be more efficient
and more flexible and yeah easier
good
is good we should figure out how to
indicate that those things are you know
how to give people pointers to the new
stuff right there's one important
difference though is that those template
functions that you write run as an
external process if this stuff crashes
your kernels yeah that's what you're
saying yes yes it's a little more
dangerous
we could have I mean yeah fine whatever
we could have some blob that runs
you know in an external process why not
I mean why not have the library why not
have an opportunity to have a harness
for the library that can run as an
external process
is that a good one we could have a right
we could have a uh
maybe there'd be some version of foreign
function load maybe maybe a different
function or maybe an option that
basically says load it in some
sacrificial executable that will
communicate with a math link
yeah that's that's kind of a little more
complicated like I think that's it
start the process God
pocket yeah there we go
no but
go ahead okay I was gonna say I put two
ideas in chat I don't know if we want to
really get into them but
um
null pointer yeah that would double
equals compare with raw pointer not
triple equals obviously
um and could be used instead of raw
pointer of zero just as a shorthand and
I picked argument type things well
there's one is just I think that equal
is a little bit you know equal does all
sorts of weird stuff
is it like sorry and it's a q function
so you know it's going to return true or
false it's not gonna if you put in an if
statement you don't have to be afraid
that it's going to return value yeah it
seems better than equals equals not
budget yeah yeah the other things are
people confuse null pointer and null
they'll try and do blah blah blah equals
equals node and that won't work oh
yeah yes
yes all right which they'll do anyway
but yeah and as a shorthand for a
function argument it's probably doesn't
add much value over just raw pointer of
zero perhaps yeah
yeah I mean we could have right I mean
you maybe you could have uh have so
there's no point or evaluate to opaque
raw pointer of zero but I think okay
pointer of zero is
pretty easy and and and maybe gets you
in
well I mean I guess we could have that
like we could have uh
that just be defined
right
yeah I don't know if that might be too
marginal to be worth it yeah I I think
we need to think about this carefully
and you do see it here like it is quite
often you know I'll pay crop pointer of
zero is I use it all the time
um
yeah
okay okay
um yeah
good stuff and it sounds good I think
we've solved basically everything the
only things might be a little bit of
ambiguity around uh some of these second
arguments to Import and Export but I
need to just do some experiments to see
how Ambiguously let's talk about this
next week Christopher I'd like to talk
about the compiler aspects right I need
to run that's good okay cheers everyone
okay okay